bonsoir soyez les bienvenu sur le
plateau de France 3 bass Normandie pour
cette soirée électorale consacrée au
premier tour des élections
départementales premièr du genre
puisqu'elle remplace les élections
cantonales si ce rendez-vous électoral a
changé de nom l'objectif est toujours le
même é lire les représentants qui
siègeront dans l'assemblée de votre
département franbé oui Émilie et 73
cantons sont à pourvoir
en basnormandie dans le cadre de ce
nouveau redécoupage puisque désormais
vous devez lire des binômes un homme et
une femme ça sera un des grands
changements puisqu'il y avait moins de
20 % de femmes dans ces nouveaux
conseils départementaux c'est comme cela
qu'on doit dire à suivre également le
rapport de force politique et peut-être
cette première information qui sera
confirmée dans quelques instants mais le
Front National qui était annoncé comme
le grand vainqueur et bien ne serait
relégué qu'en 2e position voire 3e
position on suivra canton par canton
dans quelques instants non son jusqu'à
23h hein ce soir nous serons partout
dans la région avec les réactions les
reportages que nous envoient nos équipes
sur le terrain nous serons en duplexe
des trois Conseils départementaux
puisque c'est ainsi qu'il faut les
appeler euh à cand dans le Calvados ce
sera avec pierre- Marie pot à saint-lot
dans la Manche Sylvain ruil à Alençon
dans l'Orne Nicolas Corbard Aurélie
miserie elle sera à l'affu des réactions
et des commentaires sur les réseaux
sociaux vous pouvez d'ailleurs réagir et
tweetter avec le hashtag depbn Franck
baudreau nous donnera les résultats et
des résultats commencent à tomber des
résultats que vous pouvez aussi
retrouver sur notre site internet tous
nos journalistes web sont mobilisés avec
nous également sur ce plateau Christophe
Boutin notre politologue qui va donc
décrypter ses premières élections
départementales et Emmanuel chonu notre
dessinateur bien aimé euh pour qui euh a
priori la bastomandie résisterait à la
vague fond nationale on va voir tout ça
au long de cette soirée Franck on va
revenir avec vous sur les enjeux euh de
ce premier tour le grand changement
quand même il faut le souligner c'est
l'arrivée de la parité hein oui autant
d'hommes que de femmes dans ces
assemblées départementales ser ça sera
du 5050 effectivement euh à partir du 29
mars prochain au lendemain de ce euh
second tour des départementales on va
lever une partie du suspense dans un
instant les résultats sont en train de
nous arriver on doit les vérifier quand
même parce qu'il se passe des choses
notamment des surprises dans ces trois
départements des trois département qui
devrait rester malgré tout à droite
maises questions quel sera le rapport de
force politique le suspense sera levé
dans quelques minutes pour commenter ces
résultats et bien plusieurs invités
venus de toute la région vont se
succéder sur ce plateau avec nous pour
cette première partie Christelle Le
Chevalier secrétaire départemental du
Front national dans le Calvados bonsoir
bonsoir à côté de vous Cédric Nouvelot
vous êtes secrétaire départemental de
l'UMP dans ce même département lequel
vados également membre du bureau
politique de l'UMP Sonia de la provoté
présidente de l'UD dans le C conseillère
général sortante bonsoir clatil Valter
est avec nous également député
socialiste du guvados bonsoir bonsoir et
mariejeanne Gobert vous êtes conseillère
régional du Front de gauche mais d'abord
Émilie avant d'en venir au résultat le
premier chiffre que nous sommes nous
autoriser à communiquer à commenter
c'est celui de la participation oui la
participation mais d'abord on va tout de
suite aller voir Franck Baudre car il y
a pas mal de résultats qui viennent
d'arriver effectivement les résultats
commencent à nous noyer nous partons
dans le Calvados à breadeville
l'orgueilleuse où Philippe Laurent et
Véronique Martinez à ce binôme divers
droite est qualifié pour le second tour
il arrive en tête de ce premier tour
juste devant l'autre binôme du Front
national Sylvie Lebois et George le
mararchand respectivement avec 26 6 %
des voix et le binôme du Front national
22,75 % des suffrages dans la Manche à
qu ville sur sienne c'est le Front
National qui arrive en tête de ce
premier tour le binôme de jeanyve
Lepetit Carmen maçon qui arrive avec
29,86 % au premier tour de ce scrutin
suivi par Pierre de Castellane et Marise
Edouin sans étiquette avec 28,24 % des
suffrages à 40 ans nous avons la
première triangulaire de ce premier tour
maris legof et marque Lefèvre sans
étiquette divers droite se qualifi avec
36,56 % des suffrages juste devant
Isabelle l liièvre et Franck Simon pour
le Front national 28,81 % des voix et
derrière Elisabeth Aubert Hervé well
pour le PS et ce binôme divers gauche
avec
26,85 % 80 pardonnez-moi 26,95 % des
suffrages si j'ai le encore pour
quelques résultat quelquess Coutance
toujours dans la Manche Jean-Dominique
Bourdin et Anne Arel pour la divers
droite arrivent en tête avec
40,99 % des suffrages dans ce ballontage
également un autre bidô celui de le
divers gauche Maé Aline et Grégory
galbadon avec 23,86 % des voix voà merci
Fran on va revenir sur la participation
Franck he le chiffre s'est affiché tout
à l'heure oui une participation en fait
à la hausse par rapport au dernier
scrutin départemental de 2011 c'est une
des surprises de la soirée puisque on a
mieux voté alors pour l'instant on a le
chiffre qu'à 17h il faut attendre que ça
soit validé par les préfectures mais
participation en hausse dans les trois
départements plus 1,5 dans le Calvados
plus 10 % dans dans la Manche par
rapport à 2011 et plus 2,5 % dans le
Christophe Boutin c'est je le disais un
peu surprenant par rapport à ce qui
était annoncé effectivement c'est c'est
la bonne surprise de la soirée euh même
s il y aura peut-être un différentiel
moins important pour la Manche que celui
que vous annoncez on sera peut-être plus
sur les + 5 + 6 mais effectivement il y
a une une progression très nette de la
participation euh même si on ne revient
pas sur le score qu'on avait obtenu en
2008 mais là les cantonal étaient à
l'époque couplé avec des municipales
l'explication elle tient sans doute en
très grande partie au fait que le débat
a été très largement nationalisé depuis
maintenant 15 jours le Premier ministre
et l'ensemble de la classe politique l'a
fait de manière très claire alors
effectivement ça peut être dommage parce
qu'on a moins parlé des enjeux
départementaux mais ça sans doute
ramener les électeurs aux urnes alors on
va aller un peu plus loin dans l'étude
de cette participation on va aller voir
ce qui se passe département par
département ainsi que les enjeux on va
tout de suite retrouver en direct du
conseil départemental du Calvados saamp
pierre- Marie
puot effectivement conseil départemental
c'est comme ça qu'il convient d'appeler
cette Assemblée désormais ou une
assemblée qui sera largement renouvelée
puisque seulement 33 conseillers sortant
sur 49 se représenter a priori la
majorité de semble de centre droit ne
semble pas menacé ce que confirme les
premières tendances recueillis dans les
cantons pourtant dans les couloirs dans
les bureaux où parviennent les nouvelles
les mines sont assez préoccupé en effet
le Front National est aussi a priori
bien parti pour être présent au second
tour dans bon nombre de cantons il m'est
difficile d'être plus précis puisque
nous n'avons que des résultats partiels
mais ce serait à priori le scénario de
la soirée des candidat d'ivers droite ou
UMP ou de centre droit opposé au second
tour à des binômes du Front national le
Front National qui pourrait même virer
en tête dans quelques cantons ce qui
n'est pas si surprenant si l'on se
souvient que le FN avait obtenu près de
26 % l'année dernière ici dans le
Calvados aux européennees merci Pierre
mari d'après Emmanuel Chenu Jean-Léon
Dupont n'a pas de de souci à se
faire voilà président sortant du conseil
général du Calvados qui sera avec nous
tout à l'heure sur ce plateau VO on va
aller dans la maintenant Fran voir ce
qu'il se passe à à saint-lot Sylvain
ruil oui effectivement Émilie ici on a
très très bien voté avec
44,81 % de participation c'est 10 points
moins 10 points de plus vous l'avez dit
qu'en 2011 alors ici pas de bascule de
la droite vers la gauche c'est peu
probable puisque la droite et le centre
dispose de 70 % des sièges ici c'est
bien et bien la succession de
Jean-François lerand qui pose question
ce soir et l'un de ses successeurs
désignés déclaré Philippe Bas se trouve
ce soir dans une situation proprement
incroyable puisque c'estes bulletins de
vote ont été jugés non conformes c'est
en tout cas ce qu'estime la préfecture
de la Manche ce soir la préfecture n'est
pas décisionnaire elle a donc indiqué
que c'était au président des bureaux de
vote en fonction des situations de
prendre ou non en compte ses différents
bulletins la situation vous voyez n'est
pas très clair ce qui est certain ce qui
est probable c'est que différents
concurrents peut-être engageront des
poursuites au trib tribunal
administratif vous déposerons un recours
le tribunal administratif aura jusqu'à
vendredi pour prendre une décision et la
situation est d'autant plus difficile
pour Philippe Bas qu'il était avec 55 %
des voix sur 27 communes sur 29 plutôt
bien parti pour l'emporter ce soir merci
Sylvain on a bien voté également dans
l'Orne au siège du Conseil départemental
on retrouve à alançon Nicolas
Corbard ouais tout à fait vous l'avez
dit on a plutôt bien voté ici dans
l'ordre 46,35 % de taux de participation
à 17h c'est un peu plus qu'en 2011 alors
on peut se poser encore un certain
nombre de questions première inconnue
quel va être le score d'Alain Lambert le
président du conseil général sortant qui
se présente dans le canton de damini et
qui est élu à la tête du département
depuis 2007 et puis deuxème inconnu quel
va être le score du Front national le
Front National qui avait indiqué faire
ses meilleurs résultats espérer faire
ses meilleurs résultats dans l'ordre en
tout cas en ce qui concerne la Basse
Normandie et qui est fort de ses
précédents scrutins notamment l'élection
présidentielle où Marine Le Pen avait
enregistré plus de 50 % des voix dans C
certaines communes notamment à l'est du
département et dans le Perche où on
s'attend à quelques surprises merci
Nicolas Corbard alors Sylvin nous disait
tout à l'heure que dans la Manche à
saint-l parlerit de ce qui se passe dans
le Cantau de villeedieu les poils ou
Philippe Bas possible successeur à
jean-fur ler apparemment des soucis avec
ces buletins de vote Aurélie miserie
vous suivez pour nous les les réseaux
sociaux apparemment ça réagit sur ce
sujet voilà ce qui agite les réseaux
sociaux pour le moment c'est ce qui se
passe dans le canton de Villieu les
poils le binôme UMP Philippe Bas et
Martine Le Moine auraient des bulletins
de vote NON CONFORME pourquoi et bien
vous le voyez sur ce tweet de notre
rédaction les les bultins de vote ne
sont pas monochrome comme le stipule le
code électoral une information qui vous
est développée sur notre site internet
je vous rappelle le live minute par
minute notre rédaction web euh poste en
direct les informations les résultats et
les photos de cette soirée électorale
merci Aurélie Franck alors on va essayer
d'y voir un petit peu plus clair sur
cette histoire de bulletin de vote qui
pourrait être invalidé ou pas christop
Boutin vous êtes professeur de droit
constitutionnel peut-on justement
refuser ces bulletins de vote de celui
qui était pressenti et qui est encore
pressenti ce soir comme le successeur de
Jean-François lerand à la tête du
département qu'on soit présentti c'est
une chose mais les textes sont un peu
les mêmes pour les pressenti comme pour
ceux qui on pas pressenti or en la
matière la circulaire préfectorale était
assez claire elle rappelait qu' fait du
monochrome et l'article R30 que j'ai
sous les yeux nous dit les bulletins
doent être imprimés en une seule couleur
sur papier blanc issus d'un grammage
patati patata la circulire préfectorale
précisait même que par exemple le noir
était considéré comme une couleur et
qu'il fallait pas un noir et une autre
couleur sur un bulletin a priori donc le
tribunal administratif pourrait
fortement avoir des questions à se poser
à condition qu'il y ait une plainte de
ces opposant il faut il faut saisir le
le tribul administratif oui il faut
qu'il soit saisi mal ses opposants sen
privé alors sur ce plateau justement
Cédric Nouvelot je vais m'adresser à
vous puisque vous êtes membre du bureau
politique national de l'UMP ça sera un
coup dur j'imagine pour l'UMP de savoir
que celui qui était pressenti pour
prendre la la direction de ce
département de la Manche pourrait ne pas
être élu finalement oui enfin je encore
une fois on l' prend donc je pas je pas
trant intervenir sur ce sujet il
faudrait voir effectivement quel est le
l'analyse qui est faite si effectivement
c'est cas enfin tout ça ça sera traité
donc pour l'instant c'est une surprise
oui vous nous l'apprenez ce soir c'est
une vraie surprise philba est quelqu'un
qui qui apporte beaucoup à son
territoire qui apporterait beaucoup
effectivement dans la succession
Jean-François lerand donc oui ce serait
dommage pour le ça serait très dommage
je pense pour le département alors un
mot sur les résultats qui nous sont
parvenus il y a quelques minutes les
premiers résultats je vais m'adresser là
à Christel le chevalier vous êtes
secrétaire départemental du Front
national dans le dans le Calvados le FN
qui ne réaliserait pas au niveau
national en attendant de de voir
le canton par canton qui ne réaliserait
pas le score qu'on lui prédisait par les
instituts de sondage j'attends de voir
les résultats réels déjà pour pouvoir
juger l'objectif pour le Front national
dans le Calvados justement c'est quoi
c'est décrocher deux trois sièges
maximum notre premier objectif était
déjà d'avoir des bulletins de vote dans
chaque canton nous avons réussi hein
ensuite notre électorat que je remercie
bien sincèrement aujourd'hui s bien
mobilisé et donc nous continuons notre
poussée sur notre département et on a
des résultats qui nous arrive au fur à
mesure là l'ination importante c'est que
Alain Lambert serait en ballotage
favorable le président sortant puisqu'on
parlerit Jean-François Le grandand dans
la Manche il y a quelques instants dans
l'Orne et bien Anan Lambert qui se
présente désormais sur le canton de
damini après avoir été élu sur Alenon et
sur Putange et bien serait en position
de ballotage favorable avec 33% des voix
cl Valter vous êtes député socialiste
également conseiller général sortante
sur jusqu'au 2 avril un mot sur ces
résultats on parlait de ce sondage
national numéro 1 dans ce sondage l'UMP
et ses alliés on deè position on
trouverait le Parti socialiste on
trouver je dis bien c'est une bonne
surprise pour vous écoutez moi la
première la première bonne nouvelle de
la de la journée c'est la participation
je crois que on nous avait annoncé une
une participation faible un record un
record
d'abstention et c'est vrai que là il y a
eu un sursaut des électeurs qui à
l'approche à l'approche de l'échéance se
sont se sont
mobilisés c'est vrai
qu'ensuite que les partis que les partis
républicains ce soit a maintenu leur
position et que le le frontc National ne
soit pas au score qu'il attendait ou qui
était annoncé c'est effectivement aussi
pour nous une bonne une bonne nouvelle
et vous pensez que Manuel Val eu raison
d'aller sur le terrain national et de
faire de sa bataille contre le FN
vraiment le cœur de la campagne le cœur
de sa campagne bah je crois il a pas je
crois qu'effectivement il a eu raison de
il a eu raison de faire appel aux
électeurs mais parce que ça ça pas tant
que ça je pense que si vous voulez
jusqu'à il y a 15 jours et tous ceux qui
sont ici sur le terrain le savent
jusqu'à il y a 15 jours ou 3 semaines
peu peu d'électeurs savaient qu'il y
avait une élection donc je crois que la
la la la nationaliser le ben le fait
c'est pas forcément de la nationaliser
mais le fait qu'il y a une intervention
des leaders nationaux Emmanuel Vals
n'est pas le seul à à le faire les
grands leaders des partis républicains
l' l'ont fait de la même façon il l'a
fait c'est normal et effectivement pour
rappeler qu'il y avait des enjeux qui
avait un enjeu des partis républicains à
l'égard du Front national mais qui avait
aussi des enjeux et je pense qu'on a
entendu son intervention ce soir qui
avait des enjeux départementaux dont on
a aussi insuffisamment parlé dans cette
campagne qui sont les enjeux de la
solidarité et du quotidien de nos
concityens 86 % des gens estiment que la
campagne a été malmenée ça n'était pas
conforme à leurs attentes on a
nationalisé la campagne mais c'était pas
ce qu'attendaient les gens he si l'on en
croit un sondage qui est paru cette
semaine il y a de nouveaux résultats on
surveille ça de très près qui nous
arrive voir franc Baudre vous avez des
nouveaux résultats avec jérô qui sera
élu au premier tour alors attendez vous
allez plus vite que la musique je n'ai
pas encore ce résultat
franelés des nouveau résultat j'en ai
quelquesuns pour vous avec notamment ces
premières élections les premiers
conseillers départementaux de la région
sont dans l'Orne il s'agit de Catrine
Meunier et mais si vous avez raison
Franck il suffit de lire la feuille
cathererine meunier Jérôme nu
effectivement avec 59,41 % des voix donc
dans ce canton de donfront élection au
premier tour à l'aigle c'est un ball
l'otage cette fois de deux binômes qui
se retrouveront en second tour il s'agit
de Charlin renard et de Philippe
vanourne pour l'UMP et divers droite ils
se retrouveront au second tour face à un
autre binôme celui du FN Florence MAEt
et loup Motin loup Motin qui reçoit
26,81 % des suffrages à Breton sell
c'est une triangulaire Jean Jean-Michel
Bouvier et Séverine ivard pour la divver
droite sera donc au seront au second
tour avec 33,13 % des voix juste devant
le Front National qui reçoit 27,26 % des
suffrages ainsi que Jean-Pierre
girondeau et Martine moulin avec 25 %
des voix voilà pour l'instant et des
prtion ou des premières actions de de
charbour du Charbourg 1 d'abord celle de
Frédéric Bastien qui était candidat avec
canapic pour les socialiste et puis
celle de David Marguerite pour l'UMP on
les écoute d'abord Frédéric Bastien
nous on est encore une fois sur un un
projet et je pense que les les habitants
de ce canton ont mesuré l'intérêt de
notre projet qui s'inscrit dans une
globalité de territoire avec la Grande
Région réunifiée avec un département qui
va garder des compétences notamment
sociale de proximité et nous c'est ça
qu'on défend c'est pas des calculs entre
si je vais te donner ma voix et cetera
et cetera on appelle tous les électeurs
qui ont une vision humaniste et
progressiste de ce que doit être la
politique sur notre canton et plus
largement sur notre territoire à nous
rejoindre et à voter pour nous parce
qu'il y a une dynamique qui est qui qui
est là à gauche au premier tour il faut
confirmer cette dynamique très largement
et ça je pense que c'est possible
au-delà de tous les calculs politiques
ça veut dire aujourd'hui qu'il faut
aller chercher toutes les électeurs tous
les électeurs et toutes les électrice
qui souhaitent l'alternance dans notre
canton quel qu' été leur choix au
premier tour aujourd'hui moi je je ne
parle pas aux dirigeants de tel ou tel
parti politique je parle directement aux
électrices et aux électeurs qui
souhaitent un changement pour notre
ville et qui souhait sanctionner le
gouvernement et nous sommes en position
favorable pour réussir la semaine
prochaine l'alternance dans le
centreville voilà davage un ballotage à
charbour 1 ballotage favorable pour
David Marguerite qui on s'en souvient
avait été finaliste des dernières
municipales sur cherbour il sera
quelques centaines de VO 600 voix
exactement il sera face à Frédéric
Bastian et Ana pic du Parti socialiste
et divers
gauche PhIP justement par oui on en
parlait depuis le début de cette
émission avec ce suspense autour de ces
bulletins de vote qui ne seraient pas
conforme alors que Philippe Bas qui est
annoncé comme Imposs possible successeur
de Jean-François lerand à la tête du
département et bien euh il réagissait il
y a quelques minutes à notre micro ça me
paraît ressembler à une manœuvre de
mauvais perdant animé par l'esprit de
chican car tous les bulletins des
candidats sont passés devant une
commission départementale et les miens
comme les autres ont été validés je ne
vois pas où il pourrait y avoir un
problème bon verra il y a le code
électoral vous l'avez lu tout à l'heure
Christophe
boution lescents en commission ils sont
rejetés donc pour ça va pas régler le
problème ici à suivre il faudra qu'il a
une plainte de ses adversaires mais on
le disait il a un instant aveistop on ne
doute pas qu'ils essaieront de faire
tomber le cand UMP sur ce canton de
viledieu en l'occurrence que peut-on
dire à l'heure qu'il est Christophe
Boutin sur les premiers résultats qui
nous sont parvenus est-ce qu'ils sont
déjà conformes à ce qu'on pouvait
attendre oui oui et non oui oui
globalement effectivement ce qu'on peut
constater c'est qu'il y a une il y a une
forte impantation du du Front national
on le voit quand même je j'ai les
résultats de la Manche par exemple sur
la la dizaine de de canton de la Manche
qu'on a pour l'instant obtenu on a six
cantons sur lesquels il y a le Front
national présent sur un duel et un
canton sur un une triangulaire donc
c'est pas c'est pas du tout ridicule
mais effectivement ce peut-être pas le
le rat de marée qu'on avait attendu et
on sait qu'en fait avec le le second
tour les choses vont risque de profiter
à celui qui est présent dans le duel et
dans ce cas-là sur l'ensemble de la base
Normandie les personnes présentes dans
les duels face au Front national seront
plus largement les UMP udi donc on est
bien dans le structure classique on on a
changé un petit peu ce qui confirme bien
les choses on est dans une structure
ternaire auquel cas les choix du premier
tour les divisions premier tour doivent
être pensé de manière un peu différente
avec ce qui était fait auparavant alors
on va aller entendre une autre réaction
celle du président sortant du conseil
départemental du calvado Jean-Léon
Dupont qui était candidat à Bailleux
Jean-Léon Dupon qui je vous rappelle a
succédé àornano en 2011 et qui donc
espère continuer à être président du
conseil départemental du Calvados on va
l'écouter au micro d'élè Jacques et de
Jean-Michel
guilla c'est a priori enfin en fonction
de de ce qu'on pressentait un petit peu
de ce qui se passait au niveau national
c'est assez prévisible on a quand même à
priori une participation qui est un
petit peu plus importante ce qui fait
objectivement plaisir et alors c'est on
n pas encore tous les résultats donc les
comparaisons sont objectivement
difficiles mais sur les résultats
partiels de
baayux la dernière fois il y a 4 ans
j'étais à 45 % et là je suis à
pratiquement 53 % donc c'est une vraie
satisfaction c'est un vrai plaisir c'est
un vrai bonheur et donc ben j'espère que
tout cela va se transformer dans dans
dans une huaine de jours voilà j'anlance
du pont et on va passer à un autre
président Sant c'est celui de Lorne en
l'occurrence Alain Lambert qui est
président depuis 2007 conseiller général
depuis 1985 et il est avec nous Anin
Lambert bonsoir Monsieur
Lambert bonsoir On a donné les résultats
sur votre canton il y a quelques instant
vous arrivez en tête un ballotage
favorable mais ça se joue à quelques
voix après si l'on regarde les les
chiffres vous êtes devant le Parti
socialiste Kevin baudet et Dominique
lequilerrière et en 3è position trouve
le Front national Sandrine marchand et
Daniel sellier votre
commentaire nous avons 5 points d'avance
sur le PS et nous avions quand même une
contrainte forte puisque nous avions une
dissidence à droite qui nous prend 9
points et donc le résultat que nous
obtenons est très satisfaisant c'est la
première étape savions depuis l'origine
que nous ne pourrions pas être élus au
premier tour à raison de cette
dissidence et ce soir nous pensons que
la première étape est très encourageante
et nous allons continuer cette campagne
au cours de la semaine qui vient pour
avoir un deuxème tour que nous croyons
euh
extrêmement prometteur enfin c'est notre
sentiment il n'y a pas de risque
justement dans une triangulaire à voir
les voix de de gauche notamment se
reporter sur la candidate euh du parti
parti
socialisteiste je pense que les les
électeurs sont extrêmement responsables
ils veulent que leur département soi
bien gouverné et peut-être que dans les
salles de presse on pense que on joue
avec des suffrages non je pense que
chaque électeur sait qu'il joue l'avenir
de ses enfants et donc je moi j'ai
confiance dans les électeurs ornais
est-ce que le fait de d'avoir changé de
canton plusieurs fois depuis 1985 je
Rapp il y a quelques instants vous avez
été élu sur alançon 3 euh vous avez été
élu jusqu'à aujourd'hui sur le canton de
putang vous arrivez sur damini est-ce
que vous pensez que ça sera bien perçu
notamment dans l'optique de ce deuxème
tour par les
électeurs ben vous savez je suis allé à
peu près à la rencontre de 2000
personnes et vous êtes les seuls qui en
parlent c'est-à-dire que sur les 2000
portes auxquelles j'ai sonné je n'ai pas
eu ce genre de remarque donc je trouve
qu'il y a un écart assez grand si vous
voulez entre ce dont vous parlez sur les
plateaux de télévision ce dont vous
parlez dans les salles de rédaction et
ce que les les Français vivent les
Français vivent des angoisses pour
l'emploi de leurs enfants pour leur
retraite et vous vous leur parle
d'autrre choses un peu non mais parce
que c'est la réalité Alain Lambert parce
que on constate que il y a des candidats
sur chaque canton et que on est obligé
de refaire excusez-nous leur parcours
est-ce que vous confirmez ce soir que
vous serez en cas de victoire dimanche
prochain candidat à votre succession à
la tête du département de
l'Orne évidemment je n'ai je vous l'ai
déjà dit vous posez toujours les mêmes
questions donc redites-nous c'est
intéressant de vous entendre mais non en
fait ça va se passer de la manière
suivante à l'heure où je vous parle
comme dans tous les départements nous ne
connaissons pas encore les élus dans
l'ORD nous aurons probablement 2 tiers
de nouveaux élus et donc il ne s'agit
pas de pouvoir par avance comme ça
anticip sur leurs préférences je les ai
presque tous rencontrés donc je pense
qu'ils choisiront un élu qui a de
l'expérience et qui sera capable de
faire entendre la voix de l'Orne dans la
grande Normandie voilà notre projet donc
ça veut dire que vous confirmez votre
votre candidature est-ce que l'affaire
excusez-moi de d' je vous signale que
c'est c'est la première c'est la
première fois que c'est la première fois
je l'ai fait sur votre plateau que je
serai candidat à ma succession et de
puis vous m'avez invité plusieurs fois
vous posez toujours la même question
doncés
question on pourrait avoir
d'autresulation vous faites vous faites
vous faites de la spéculation très bien
on suivra tout cela et on suivra
notamment ce secondendsjà j'entends déjà
par avance votre prochaine question qui
est toujours la même d'ailleurs donc je
voudrais vous dire la chose suiv les
ornets ne sont pas toujours les les
ORNIS ne sont pas toujours contents
qu'on les traite comme un petit
département comme des petits électeurs
comme des petits pees personnes qui
n'ont pas le niveau des euh des autres
départements et dans une grande
Normandie les ORNIS ont envie que leur
voix soit entendu et je m'engage devant
eux ce soir à faire entendre leur voix
voilà la vote a été entendue ce soir en
tout cas monsieur lenvert merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct
d'alançonour on va retourner voir Franck
Baudre pour de nouveaux résultats Franck
oui Émilie direction le Calvados dans le
canton de trévière où le Front national
le Front national arrive en tête avec
35,53 % des voix c'est le binôme de
Philippe chaperon et de Sandrine Linares
devant le binôme d'hiver droite et UMP
Patricia Gadid duuken et Jean-Pierre
Richard qui obtiennent
32,75 % des suffrages à Cabour Olivier
CIN et Béatrice Guillaume arrivent en
tête de ce premier tour avec 37,42 % des
voix c'est un binôme divers droite et
UMP devant le Front national également
martial Chéry et Adel David qui
obtiennent
24,18 % des voix dans la Manche le score
de Philippe Bas qui vient de nous
parvenir Philippe B et Martine Lemoine
qui obtienent donc
47,79 % des voix juste devant Catherine
Durand et Jacquy ledormer du Front
national ce binôme obtient 22,78 % des
suffrages et puis un petit tour dans
l'ordre si vous me le permettez
plais à radon dans le canton de radon
nous avons une élection dès le premier
tour il s'agit de Christophe de
et de Béatrice metteyer qui obtiennent
donc
51,42 % desist Bor ouais Christophe de
Bor un autre président sortant nous
attend mais il ne se représente pas
c'est Jean-François Le grandrand 17 ans
de présidence 17 ans à la tête du
département de la Manche Franck ouais là
c'est au moins une certitude il ne sera
pas candidat à sa succession dimanche
prochain puisquil a annoncé il y a très
longtemps sur notre antenne également
comme Alain Lambert d'ailleurs c'était
deux décisions officialisées sur notre
plateau bonsoir Jean-François
lerand bonsoir simplement dans quel état
d'esprit êtes-vous ce soir pour
commencer à titre personnel j'avais
autant alors à titre personnel j'avais
autant le stress que lorsque j'étais
moi-même candidat parce que j'avais le
stress pour tous ceux qui m'ont
accompagné au cours de ces 107 années
notamment dans les dernières et qui
étaient de nouveau candidat alors je
veux saluer la victoire de ceux qui sont
passés au premier tour et dire tous mes
encouragement à ceux qui vont avoir à
affronter un deuxème tour on a parlé au
début de cette émission des ennui
peut-être on verra cela dans les jours
qui viennent ou les heures qui viennent
peut-être directement de celui qui est
annoncé queà votre successeur Philippe
Bas ces bulletins de vote ne seraient
pas conforme à la réglementation
électorale votre commentaire monsieur le
grand écoutez je je ne vais faire aucun
commentaire j'ai appris un peu comme
tout le monde ce soir qu'il avait cette
difficulté je sais que ces bulletins ont
été validés par la commission de
propagande et donc il n'a pas eu à les
refaire alors maintenant on va voir un
peu quelle sera la la suite de de cette
de cet épisode ceciétant il arrive en
largement en tête dans le territoire
d'élection de de villelieu et je lui
souhaite bon courage pour le deuxème
tour je ne vais pas faire plus de
commentairire ça se traitera est-ce que
c'est le le meilleur candidat à votre
succession écoutez je n'ai jamais fait
de commentairire sur le sujet ce sont
les nouveaux conseillers départementaux
qui aont à élire un président mais c'est
vrai qu'il a de par son passé de par son
histoire son historique et les
compétences qui sont les siennes toute
toute raison de briller la présidence du
conseil départemental la progression du
frond national elle éta annoncée elle
est moins que ce qui était prévu votre
votre commentaire là aussi je sais que
vous avez combattu le FN sur sur ces
idées pendant plusieurs
années et je continue de les combattre
et clairement je m'en réjouis résultat
qu'ils ont encaissé c'est le résultat
d'un d'un double d'une d'une comment
dirais-je peut-être d'une erreur
d'appréciation d'cun ont voté le frond
national pensant qu'ils étaient dans une
élection apportée nationale alors que en
fait il s'agit de l'avenir du
département de la Manche et que dans C à
cet égard je souhaite que la raison
revienne en tout cas j'appelle dans les
CIR dans les cas où il y aura un duel au
2uxème tour ou une une trois
candidatures au deème tour avec la
présence du Front national à votter
contre le nationale à vootter pour des
candidats qui appartiennent à ce qu'on
appelle traditionnellement le Front
républicain j'aime pas trop cette
expression mais à ceux qui ont une vraie
une vraie intention en ce qui concerne
le département et qui ne viennent pas là
pour faire de la figuration à un niveau
national mais qui se préoccupe
réellement des sujets
départementaux merci Jean-François
lerand d'avoir répondu en direct depuis
l'Hôtel du
Département qui a transformé
Jean-François lerand en en général de
Gaulle oui depuis on va les retrouver on
va retrouver Aurélie miserie pour voir
comment réagissent les réseaux sociaux
Aurélie écoutez Émilie puisque nous
étions dans la Manche avec Jean-François
lerand je voulais vous vous signaler ce
tweet du député UMP de la Manche
Philippe goselin qui se félicite des
bons scores de la droite dans la Manche
mais note la progression du FN et donc
appel au travail je voulais également
vous dire que vous pouvez nous suivre
aussi sur notre compte Twitter euh où
nous publions les informations mais
aussi les coulisses de cette émission
comme ici la régie tranche merci Aurélie
on va on va aller euh écouter une autre
réaction qui nous vient de l'Orne celle
de Lionel steffel pour le Front national
on devrait tourner aux alentours des 25
30 % je pense dans l'ORD ce qui est
quand même déjà un beau score pour des
soi-disant euh élections locales qui
tournent bien bien sûr au niveau
national parce qu'on sait très bien que
le local ils n'ont plus beaucoup
maintenant de de choses à dire à faire
tout tout se dirige soit au national
voire à l'Europe quoi maintenant donc on
se plaint pas de no nos scores au
contraire on est très content je pense
qu'on aura des deuxièm tours quasiment
partout voilà Lionel stffen le patron du
Front national dans leorn franc ouais
des deuxiè tours partout dans l'Orne on
les évoqué également avec notre
correspondant tout à l'heure au Conseil
départemental du Calvados Pierre Marie
po dans le Calvados Sonia la provoté
justement vous êtes présidente de de
l'UDI dans ce département ça serait une
déception pour vous de de voir affronter
le FN au second tour dans ce département
département centriste bien écoutez
d'abord je pense pas que ce soit le
Front National qui soit partout en tête
dans les dans les les cantons du
département du calvado c'est absolument
pas le cas
donc le centrisme voilà
donc l'Union de la Droite et du centre
qui s'est quand même réuni autour de
valeurs quand même qui sont communes et
plutôt humaniste a bien fonctionné c'est
bien elle qui est sur le devant de la
scène dans le département du Calvados
donc je pense que déception ou pas c'est
une réalité ce vote était annoncé on l'a
tellement annoncé que il a fini par
arriver moi je dis les choses très
simplement par rapport à cette question
c'est une élection
locale les électeurs ont voté se sont
comporté comme de vrais citoyens ils ont
on les montre du doigt depuis des
semaines en leur disant vous êtes de
mauvais républicains ils se sont
déplacés et le deuxème tour va être
l'occasion de leur donner l'opportunité
de de voter pour des équipes qui portent
un projet pour le département pour leur
canton et tout simplement d'oublier
cette parenthèse nationale un peu
médiatico poliitique parisienne et de
revenir à la réalité de ce qu' a un
département dans une grande région
demain et c'est très important pour le
quotidien des habit quel doit être le
positionnement des élus de gauche du
Parti socialiste mais également je vais
m'adresser celle qui n'a pas parlé pour
l'instant c'est mariean Gobert qui est
du Parti communiste français du Front de
Gauche quelle posture doivent avoir
justement ces candidats en vue du second
tour est-ce qu'ils doivent après appeler
à faire élire le candidat de l'UMP ou de
l'UDI dans le calvado écoutez je pense
qu'on peut pas s'inscrire dans une
démarche aussi simple que ça il faut
d'abord tirer les une analyse du premier
tour aujourd'hui on a peu de résultats
et c'est de la faute de personne donc on
est un peu à l'aveugle donc je pense que
une analyse des élections ça demande des
une information clair et et puis de
prendre le temps justement de permettre
aux différentes composantes de gauche et
de droite d'ailleurs de se réunir pour
savoir ce qu'elles ont à faire moi je
voudrais dire quand même quelque chose
qui me paraît important euh on l'a noté
il y a un recul de l'abstention je pense
que ce recul de l'abstention c'est pas
un hasard non plus on a il faut quand
même pas oublier qu'on est dans une
situation politique économique très très
très particulière qu'on a eu des
événements récents dramatiques et qu'on
a eu une mobilisation d'extrême
importance en France et aujourd'hui les
électeurs sont encore sous le choc de la
gravité de la situation y compris un je
pense que c'est important de le soulerès
conr pass la semaine
praine Frier je n'ai pas encore parlé je
n'ai pas encore parlé je pense que il
est important que la parole politique
qui est ici présente puisse s'entendre
donc je le dis gravité extrême les
électeurs sont encore sous le choc ils
son mobilisé sur des valeurs
républicaines et ils ont montré
aujourd'hui effectivement qu'ils veulent
une politique de gauche ça je pense que
c'est important et c'est ce message là
qu'il faut porter au au deuxème tour ils
ont montré qu'il faisaient la différence
entre la droite et l'extrême droite et
la gauche aujourd'hui la gauche ne fait
pas encore le plein de voie et il me
semble que l'enjeu pour ce deuxème tour
c'est exiger cette politique de gauche
mais aussi de l'exiger dans les semaines
et les mois qui vont venir parce qu'en
2012 on a élu un président pour une
politique de gauche et malheureusement
c'est aujourd'hui les conséquences de
cette cette situation on a quand même
encore près de 50 % d'abstentionnist
voilà vous avez rattrapé votre temps de
parole depuis le début réponse de Cédric
Nouvelot qui est secrétaire
départemental de l'UMP dans le CALV du
bureau politique nation effectivement
nous on nous prédisait d'une part à FN
qui allait devenir le premier parti de
France et d'autre part une abstention
record elle est forte l'abstention
malheureusement mais moins forte que ce
qu'on pensait et contrairement à ce qui
se dit sur le plateau moi je pense que
c'est pas un réflexe effectivement du
National c'est au contraire un réflexe
du local les la population s'est
mobilisée pour des locau ils ont compris
la difficulté et la problématique et
l'aleure au quotidien et c'est ça qui a
fait voter c'est justement la
nationalisation du débat ce le disait
tout à l'heure n'est pas forcément la
réponse à ce qu'il faut j'ai pas non
plus la même analyse en disant que les
les la population veut une politique de
gauche quand on voit les scorses faut
quand même rappeler que le MP udi le
centre ce soir l'Union de la Droite et
du centre on fait quand même un score au
niveau national on est entre 32 et 34 %
alors qu'on expliquait qu'il y aurait un
effondrement ce qui montre au contraire
qui a une volonté et un choix d'aller
vers autre chose on le voit sur nos
cantons donc encore une fois la
politique menée euh par par LiIon la
droite et du centre proche du terrain
sur l'efficacité sur la nécessité en
période de crise économique d'avoir une
autre politique que celle qui est menée
et par plus de proximité avec la
population et Ben se traduit dans les
chiffres et effectivement on espère
qu'au deuxième tour tout ça se
concrétisera pour envoyer un maximum
effectivement de nos de nos de nos
futurs élus au conseil départemental
vouagir allez-y non je dis que
effectivement sur ce deuxième tour il y
a un enjeu magistral mais je dirais pas
t ce que je viens de dire j'ai dit que
vous aviez quand même tendance quand
certains s'expriment sur le plateau de
laisser largement la parole mais c'est
vrai que vous n'avez pas toujours la
même attitude avec l'ensemble des des
des partenaires et des invités ici
présents dans vous attendez réponse de
CL est-ce que vous partagez cet avis
attendez moi j'ai envie de parler du
fond là vous m'avez interrogé sur le
deuxème tour et sur la perspective du 2è
tour moi je voudrais sur le deè tour et
dans la perspective qui est qui est la
notre aujourd'hui on a une idée qui est
encore quand même flou de la réalité
aujourd'hui donc on on peut
difficilement on verra quand on avancera
dans la soirée je pense que il y a eu
quand même un élément concernant la
gauche c'est que la gauche s'est
présenté aux électeurs éclaté donc on
regardera ce que F fait le total
justement avec votre cègue moi en ce qui
me concerne j'ai porté le message de
l'unité j'ai porté le message de l'unité
depuis le début il n'a pas été entendu
d' tact mais en tout cas pour la suite
et pour le second tour là où nous serons
présents j'espère que les partis de
l'ensemble de la gauche seront se réunir
deuxièmement dans les hypothèses où nous
aurons comme vous l'avez évoqué et comme
la la question qui a été posé quand nous
aurons un candidat du Front National et
un candidat de la droite républicaine la
le choix que nous ferons sera de faire
barrage au Front National et de faire un
vote républicain nous sommes extrêmement
clairs là-dessus et il y a pas de
message très
clair extrêmement clair
ex toujours été notre très courte de
Christ le cheval toujours ce même
discours finalement donc les partis de
gauche vont s'unir et je suppose que
bien entendu gauche droite tout m contre
le Front national part pas les mêmes
valeurs excusez-moi mais vous avez quand
même un électorat qui est entre 20 et
30% pour le Front
national vous le propose je suis désolé
vous avez plusieurs par de gauche
plusieurs partis de droite des partis
centristes alors pourquoi est-ce que
vousz le National c'est qu même domage
avec le travail que vous avez à faire au
niveau
conse
récore des résultats qui vient de nous
parvenir exement pour séparer clole
Valter et Madame le chevalier allons à
saint-hilère d'arcé dans la Manche il y
avait là-bas deux binômes qui se
présentaient le premier Jacy Bouvet et
Karine Mailleux un binôme sans étiquette
et bien ce binôme obtient
7288 % des voix face au Front national
de Gérard léné et viestlava padzerska
qui donc obtient 27,12 % des voix c'est
donc une élection dès le premier tour à
saint-hilère du harcou direction
saint-lot à présent où François Brière
et Adel omomé le lièvre obtiennent 41,53
% des suffrages ballotage favorable
juste devant nadch Daniel et Roland
Derbez du Front national le Front
National qui obtient
20,27 % des voix un petit tour dans
l'Orne commençons par Argentan 2 une
fois n'est pas coutume où Jacques Amot
et Brigitte le cœur du Front national
arrive en tête avec 27,38 % des
suffrages juste devant Florence et
cobichon et Philippe gidouard du Parti
socialiste le PS qui obtient
23,57 % des voix franc on va aller
retrouver Pierre Marie pot au siège du
Conseil départemental du calvado c'est
ce que Pierre Marie les le rapport des
forces politiques apparaît est-ce que
vous en savez un peu
plus alors il faudrait avoir pour cela
l'intégralité des résultats ce qui n'est
pas encore tout à fait le cas l'ambiance
est assez studieuse chacun scrute ses
résultats qui tombe 1 à un le président
sortant du conseil général jeanl 11 du
on vient d'arriver tout à l'heure
Jean-Léon Dupont crédité de 44 % avec sa
coéquipière dans son canton de baayu il
sera opposé au binôme du Front national
c'est un scénario assez classique ce
soir à Noé toutefois quelques petites
surprises à turarcour c'est la gauche
qui vient en tête dans une triangulaire
et puis enfin dans l'agglomération de
camp dans la ville de camp le
dépouillement n'est pas encore tout à
fait terminé mais a priori le PS résiste
plutôt bien h les bureaux de vote ont
fermé à 18h Christophe Boutin a priori
dans le Calvados notamment sur quand le
PS résiste oui
effectivement c'était un peu le ce qu'on
attendait on se demandait s'il y aurait
cette cette vague bleue que qui était
irrésistible au municipal du moin à
laquelle la gauche a eu la peine de
résister elle résiste effectivement
beaucoup mieux que que prévu fa remarer
quand même les scores très très
importants fait par le Front national y
compris dans les zones urbaines Franck
Bier une réaction encore de vos invités
on approche de la fin de cette première
partie je vais m'adresser à Sonia de la
proté vous êtes élu du département du
calvatos est-ce que demain il pourrait
avoir des accords techniques euh de
politique sur sur ce département du
Calvados avec les élus du Front national
écoutez je pense que la question se pose
même pas chacun sera libre de son vote
vous elle se pose dans d'utres
départements c'est pour ça que je me
permet de vous la poser ce soir bien
écoutez je pense qu'au niveau du
département du cavados il y a pas de
question chacun choisira en son am et
conscience on a l'avantage d'être énu
sur notre nom au conseil général au
conseil départemental demain et donc
l'indépendance des élus est
importante ce seront aux élus de décider
qui sera le président demain et les
petites affaires boutiquières n'ont pas
lieu d'être dans cette enceinte c'estc
Nouvelot pour l'UMP même dialogue pas de
discussion aucune avec él sou ce que
l'on souhaite c'est effectivement qu'un
maximum d'électeurs soit des place pour
voter pour les équipes le rassemblement
de la droite et du centre de façon à
pouvoir répondre au vrais enjeux de la
population c'est ce que c'est cette
campagne qu'on a mené avec Christine
Durand c'est celle qu'on mené beaucoup
de de binôes sur les autres cantons
c'est l'enjeu principal et effectivement
on espère que les électeurs feront
confiance au travail de terrain et puis
à la logique d'une proposition
constructive pour le département ti
merci Cédric nouelot on arrive à la fin
de cette première partie vous pouvez
bien sûr continuer à réagir sur Twitter
avec le hashtag
depepbn on y reviendra dans la suite de
cette émission avec vos réactions donc
on se retrouve dans un quart d'heure
pour plus de résultats encore peut-être
tous les résultats dans cette deuxième
partie de nouveaux invités des réactions
des reportages de toutes nos équipes
mobilisé d'ailleurs sur notre site
internet l'info continue si vous venez
de nous rejoindre mais je vous invite à
y aller et puis on vous donne
rendez-vous à 21h15 pour la deuxè partie
de cette soirée électorale consacrée au
premier tour de ces élections
départementales Merci à VOUS 5 d'êt
venir sur ce plateau on se retrouve à
21h15 à tout à l'heure Fran tout à
l'heure
[Musique]